le timing est parfait le jour où le
gouvernement adopte le projet de loi sur
l'accord interprofessionnel
renault obtient la signature de deux
syndicats pour entériner son projet de
compétitivité après la cfe cgc force
ouvrière lui a emboîté le pas ce
mercredi et j'aimerais qu'on va gagner 3
ans et au bout de trois ans on sait très
bien que henry passé on nous parle de
2007 dans un premier temps voire 2020
donc voiture et qu'on est déjà
pratiquement garantie jusqu'en 2020 bon
ils comptent sur des voitures de nos
partenaires milton épique fortement des
moeurs la direction de la marque au
losange s'engage à ne fermer aucun site
à ne pas adopter de plan social pour y
arriver
l'accord prévoit d'augmenter la
production française avec au moins sept
cent dix mille véhicules par an dont 110
milles à l' usine de flins en
contrepartie les salariés acceptent
d'augmenter leur rythme de travail
passant de 32 à 35 heures est de voir
leur salaire gelé en 2013 contrairement
à la volonté de l'entreprise malgré ses
engagements pris jusqu'en 2016 la cgt
reste fermement opposée au projet
au-delà de ces deux véhicules zoé et
clio 4 qui sont produits sur l' usine de
flins aujourd'hui dans l'avenir plus
lointain
au delà de 2016 il n'y a pas de véhicule
aujourd'hui dans les tiroirs de renault
qui pourrait rentrer dans le gym de
flins d'ici à 2016 plus de 8200 postes
seront tout de même supprimé le projet
sera présenté le 12 mars en conseil
central d'entreprise il pourrait être
signé dès le lendemain